in the lobby of the headquarters of
Ramsey solutions Lane and Krista are
here lanes a big rock star on the
Internet youtuber hey guys how are you
doing great welcome I've been following
all your activity on Twitter I'm good
today congratulations on being debt-free
thank you yeah I know a little about you
from all of that activity but we want
everybody else to catch up so I don't
know this how much debt have you paid
off $70,000 worth of debt good for you
how long did it take I had two years and
ten months okay very cool and household
income during that time sixty thousand
started off about 40 and then we got to
about sixty okay what was the increase
from you have she gets a raise as she's
a schoolteacher every year almost every
year and then I started being able to
make more through my youtube channel the
funny rats so we do daily vlogs on our
on our YouTube channel but a good push
there it's funnier and funnier at that's
right so you can subscribe yes our
family we documented our whole debt free
journey oh really yeah so you see us go
from that seventy thousand all the way
down to the zero on that exciting last
payment day I love it I love it so are
you tied in to my buddy shake our on
anyway well yeah I've met him and we
talked and he's a great guy and he's one
that got me wanting to do your plan okay
I started watching him back in 2009 yeah
and he was talking about how he was
getting some money in whether he was
gonna pay off his van or whether he was
gonna go blow it on something and of
course he made the wise decision to to
pay off his van so yeah okay his channel
I started watching it and it just really
motivated me so that's what started the
whole thing that absolutely Anna so
Krista he comes in not only is he doing
a YouTube channel the funny rats but now
he's watching another guy on YouTube mr.
Hanna he says okay we're gonna get out
of debt you're going down married to a
crazy man
well we actually um we were laying as a
land man and we were doing okay and we
were saving money but not
as much as we should and he was laid off
three days before our daughter was born
oh my goodness and so we had about eight
months of income saved up and at the end
of eight months we realized this is not
going to continue to work we need to do
something different so that Christmas we
bought your book because he had heard
about you shake are a tandem gift each
other and we decided that January first
we were doing the Total Money Makeover
and January 2nd I found I was pregnant
with our son just proof that you can you
know Blaine had a huge gigantic decrease
in his income and we had two children
and we were still able to do the program
and get there so on top of the 70,000
there's also all the bills that come
with having some kids yeah you know
absolutely so what kind of debt was the
70,000 I love it 60,000 was student
loans and 10,000 was you know all the
other little stuff cars and like a
little credit card so which one of you
stirred loans both of you it was me
gonna be a teacher then yeah what do you
teach biology high school oh man good
for you thank you you know a lot of
patients love it and who's the low
princess sitting on the throne here this
is Amelia Amelia is beautiful how old is
she she's four four years old and your
son's name again Jacques Jacques okay
very cool and he's old he's two and a
half two and a half yeah so he's been
here through this whole journey he has
been he's your little debt free
barometer that's right so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is working together working
together absolutely and I always say
there's the how you know we all know the
how but you need to have a passion
behind it the why behind it once you
figure out that that's what's gonna like
the fire underneath you to really want
to get out of debt yeah yeah there's got
to be something driving it exactly and a
couple of kids and that'll do it for one
thing let's go you know it's time for us
to be grown-ups that's enough sometimes
but sometimes it gets to be even
something bigger I want to completely
change my family tree right exactly
exactly
I want to completely change our whole
way
life and yeah that'll light you off on a
whole lot of wonderful paths along the
way so what was the worst money fight
you had during this two years and ten
months our worst thing is usually like I
love to shop and we were trying to be so
gizelle intense that we were not ever
doing blow money and that was probably
something that we should have done
through the whole because I and I would
always like kind of slip up at some time
and you know come home with a pair of
shoes and that would kind of usually
start an argument so I think that if we
had to give people advice it would be
like you definitely need the blow money
envelope um you because it's an you know
it's really hard to just sew shoes that
aren't in the budget the funny rats
really aren't funny okay that's fine
good for you guys you're awesome
congratulations thank you feel to
accomplish this amazing I tell you that
we listen to your radio program a lot
and I used to think it was so silly how
you would scream freedom whenever people
would do their dead free scream and I
never understood it until about three
days after we made that last payment
Sallie Mae and I was I remember I was
driving and down a road and Lafayette
and I just felt like so incredibly light
and I thought well this is why he
screams freedom cuz you really do feel
free and lighter after that huge burden
is off of you Wow well well said once
you kick Sallie Mae out there's all kind
of freedom didn't enjoy living with eBay
and Craigslist as we were selling
everything in our house I love it so as
a meal you been practicing or debt free
scream they both have yeah oh yeah
shocks - Wow good good all right well
you guys I'm very proud of you
congratulations I'm praying finally get
to meet you in person and you've
appreciate you chronicling this you've
inspired other people as you've gone
along yes and we'll give you one more
plug it's the funny rats yes I'm saying
that right funny right all one word and
you can find him on YouTube and see the
whole deal there yep and learn more
about these guys but there's a lot of
fun stuff happening on YouTube a lot of
young entrepreneurs doing some neat
stuff over there just like my buddy Shay
Carl he does amazing things
you know he's uh he's gone he's even
gone past amazing yeah tell me about it
he's doing all right he's gonna be okay
I think he's gonna make all right you
guys congratulations very well done Lane
and Krista Amelia and Jaques count it
down $70,000 paid off two years in ten
months making 40 than 60,000 a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three - awesome
well done you guys are a beautiful
family that's fun that is seriously fun